ils sont passionnés de vélo et le
produit qu'il s'apprête à mettre sur le
marché suisse est déjà un vif intérêt
chez les cyclistes
c'est un produit qui vous sur ton dit
d'angelo qui se connecte à une
application mobile qu'on a développé et
qui transforme ton vélo en ville horizon
fixé à la potence smartradios activités
qu'on s'approche avec le téléphone dans
l'application mobile suit d'entrer
l'adresse où on veut aller et ce matin
le vol guider virage par virage à
destination
le cercle lumineux et diète de cyclistes
dans les déplacements
il prévient à la proche d'un virage ou
d'un changement de direction semaine à
l'eau donne une idée de la distance qui
reste à parcourir plus la circonférence
du cercle s'illumine plus on approche de
la destination chine dans combien de
temps je vais arriver à peu près 100 kg
est deux chiffres sans qu'ils aient
d'écran donc c'est une façon vraiment
utile de savoir où j'en suis c'est une
notification à peine
l'appareil peut également prévenir le
cycliste si quelqu'un tente de le
joindre au téléphone
et lorsqu'on s'éloigne du vélo soit à
l'eau se transforme en système d'alarmé
tous fait automatiquement dans une
technologie à laquelle on n'a pas besoin
de penser
l'appareil qui sera livré à compter de
mai prochain coûte un peu plus de 100
dollars la technologie proposée par le
groupe d'entrepreneurs montréalais a
connu un succès instantané sur les
plates formes de sociaux financement
récoltant près d'un demi million en
seulement quelques semaines il si
vincent maisonneuve race au canada
montréal